葉月のしナップ今日はどうかターン
始めた吉備たちはお菓子食べる有機物の一種で犯すというものな日食べたお菓子を娯楽
として生きているわけでもない
その中でも某ゾーンのね福岡市がとても人気があるきみだぞを食べたことがあると
まあその中でも一番有名なのがこちら坊ディーラーこういう某増のお菓子がこの世界に
はたくさんて待っているんだが君たち非常に考えが甘い今の地球上何が起きるか分から
ない
ちょっとしたらいいでこれてその時に持っているものがポッキー
だけだったりすることがあるかもしれない持つ者が某ぞお菓子だけだと時
助けることができるのかいいなその確率は非常にきっかり例えばなんだかもし今ここで
本地俺が起きるとしましょう私がこの隙間に落ちてしまったらもう手をこのなんか指も
これで床に引っかからない
こういう時にこうやって勃起を掴んでこのがを超えて集まった行くが無理
何でもここを使うしかないわけですよこうやってなんだか力を入れてもつながって帰っ
てこれれば一番いいんだけどもうこの時のこのおかしいの強度が私はとても気になる今
のケースにおいてもっちもな
某増の丘しんどい最大の危機の時に備えてこの暴走のおかしなに思っていればいいか
今回は冒頭の歌詞を色々準備してみたみんなそれぞれ強度が違うので夫
になった時に引っ掛けてフックの代わりとなるこの部分の棒状のお菓子はどれが一番
強いのか網状のたちの強度ナンバーを今回は分かっていきたいと思う
出会い5この2つの鯛を使って
実刑をします2本使いますそういう感じでこういう感じで台の上に本を言ってこの上に
重りを乗せますそれでこの日本の包丁農家しで耐えれるかどうかを図っていきます最終
的に一番重いものを乗せられていた選手イエロー状のお菓子が勝つという今日競技者に
ゼッケンになっておりますこの実験ある意味では
は ok たちのウェイトリフティング大会どの某増のお菓子が一番強いのでしょうか
はい2017年度京都選手権大会某ぞお菓子の部が始まりました10今日は私じゃ
なかっ進めさせて頂きますよろしくお願いします
最初のプレイヤーはこちらポッキー日本代表でございます
ファーストステージはガムテープということでこの多さに耐えられるかがポイント今皆
さん
さーど出る1st ステージクリア
すばらしいですまずは日本代表をクリアしました次のシェアになったやつですねつぎの
選手はこちらポッキー国細
この重量級の者や怒りのリックを成していくかがポイントとなっております今
選手が入場してきました場所とに形でございますしっかりと足を揃えて着地する
いざ
ザートでるん
うん
服やよろしいです海釣りなんと語りましたね
さあ通常選手はこちらぷりっ地でございます
引退が懸かった試合となっております今年最後の挑戦
さんがショートにしっかりしてこここれは d っが足りないからローリングステップ
ですねさ
大丈夫かん
うん
クリアはなしーローリングステップでのクリアとなり得点が下されますね次の選手は
こちらポッキーアーモンド日立体にアーモンドを取っている選手でございます
1人神だった自動そうでしょうかスチール目が人に負傷しましたね
surf 乗車中名の便もがんばれるか良いクラッシュ
車
運命の瞬間です
呉宮です何とか優勝への第1歩を踏み出せました
次の選手はこちら突放です今までの選手はちょっと作りが違っておりまして中にチョコ
が入っていると
果たしてこの試合どう出るか
計測中ですん
素晴らしい意外と余裕をもってクリアですかね続いている選手はこちら今大会唯一の
女性参加さん大きいいちごでーす
ハート型になっておりますがこれが果たしてどう出るか耐えられるか
今測定開始です
ん
うん
口野ギリギリですねおやどうされたのでしょうか
プリッツあろう外壁てるで失格ですねここでプリッツローストが失格
さあ原の1回戦でテカリ回戦の出場選手はこちらの5名となっておりますよりして
グリーの名門高校進むで芝刈り
どうする試合展開になるのか第2ステージは多いを食べござ
あれっいや思い始めたんでさぁ台
エステージ最初の選手はおっきい500ml ですね500グラムほどのお守りがあり
ます得られるかポッキー
今挑戦卒業んとご飯失敗ここで日本国旗失格です
でも味は美味しいです続いての挑戦者はこちらぷりっずですね
一体かかっております認知の短さがちょっと弱点ですがどう出るか
ん
音ここで視覚プリズを耐えられたかった課題リリースでも美味しい続いてはこちら
ポッキーアーモンドクラッシュ
つく地区のアーモンドがどう出るかですねこの試合は500グラブを得られるか運命の
瞬間です
うん
これは
素晴らしい初の第3ステージクリア
この勢いで勝ちたいトッポ店主の挑戦です
トップはなかったチョコレートなので時間が経てば経つほどスタミナ切れが
弱て避難できますさあ500g のおーいお茶
耐えられるか
ん
これは
うん
ん
クリア
いいいい
さあこの勢いに乗って勝っていきたい本体が友人の女性店主ポッキ15500g の
おーいお茶与えられるかどうか
今この顔ですさあいよいよ決勝戦上がってきた選手はこちらポッキーアームブラスト
トッポでございますさあこれで一番硬い一番強度の硬い選手が決まる
結晶粒野菜ジュースフォース業
利用させていただいております1本まで200グラムの重さがある徐々に充足やして
いくスライド防止が最をとっていただいております
さあなにその選手はこちらポッキーアーモンドチョコ
まずは200グラムのたクリア
ここからどんどん野菜1日これ1本が積み重ねていく
400g のクリアをが山場です600g
[音楽]
耐えられるか
ん
おっとここで骨折
いやぁああああああ
残念な結果ですねー
これでトップが勝てばこの大会で優勝者のトッポん
那覇までチョコたっぷり結構時間が経っておりますので中のチョコが溶けてきている
その10th ためでは持つのかどうか知らないです試験官がむせていますさあに
グラマー乗ったここから600までいけるかよ tegra 分のタイガートッポ
かなりそれているぐにゃっと曲がっているが耐えられるか
あった
彼らの多いのゴールが拍手ガーの塩ホテルいけれがー
やってくれるローター
パンッ2位
1 year
[拍手]
me
一ああああ